Oddio Ma sei davvero tu Ma che fine ha
fatto la ex compagna di classe quella
piena di brufoli coi baffetti mo ho
saputo che qualcuno si sposa Chi
l'avrebbe mai detto a vedere un po' più
vicino Scusa eh ho dimenticato gli
occhiali da vista a casa un po' più
vicino ancora un po' Wow carino semplice
di poche pretese perfetto per una come
te vedi i casi della vita io single e tu
che ti stai per sposare io gli uomini li
spavento perché sono troppo
irraggiungibile troppo Independent Women
e quindi per paura di fallire
preferiscono provarci con quelle che non
sanno né di carne che di pesce e la data
c'è già Ah adoro Pensa che ho già il
vestito per l'occasione Cioè In realtà
L'avevo comprato per il matrimonio di
una mia amica che poi non si è più
sposata e quindi lo posso riciclare per
il tuo Ah è tutto bianco non ti offendi
se avessero bianco il tuo matrimonio
vero Ma lui chi è Lo conosco Fammi
vedere una foto Beh sembra simpatico è
più grande di te vero No perché vedo la
stempiatura i capelli bianchi Vabbè alla
fine l'importante è che ti voglio bene
Vabbè allora vado mi ha fatto super
piacere rivederti brufolina
Oddio scusa D'altronde soprannome per
sempre aspetto l'invito Eh